Heidi is in Phoenix hey Heidi welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show
hi there you great to talk to you hi
Chris fellow yeah your question for
Chris or me um well my question is for
kind of crisp and you we are on baby
step three I think we're almost finished
we're really eager to get to baby step
four because of our ages and we just
weren't sure how much to save to
complete baby step three whether we
qualify more towards the three months or
the six months to really be able to go
to that 15%
okay well hi do you know the drill right
Dave's been telling you for years you
sit down and you take a look you
understand your budget and your expenses
it really boils down to you and your
husband making that decision are you
more comfortable with three or six
months okay that's it that bottom line
but I want you guys together to make
that decision again get on the same page
if you say three months let's let it be
three months and then move forward now
you can plug in and start to do baby
step four yeah so uh how stable are your
incomes I'm pretty stable and I'm going
to increase pretty significantly soon so
what do you do for a living what you do
for a living my husband works for the
city and I am finishing nursing school
so I will be a full-time there soon okay
that's that's where the increase comes
the significance comes he okay so here's
the thing you have two incomes and you
have two very marketable very stable
incomes nursing you can get a job in 20
minutes and and he's steady with the
city right yeah so these are great
incomes and there's two of them if you
had one income that was unstable
we might cheat towards the six-month
side but you have two incomes so you've
got diversification and they're both
stable marketable jobs so and increasing
so I think you're very safe at the three
months side okay that sounds great well
we just ordered retire inspired and got
our shipping confirmation and we can't
wait to dig in and dive in the baby step
for that sounds exciting
thank
Heidi I appreciate you all and great job
attacking baby step number two getting
more of your money back and building
your own legacy so keep up the good work
very well done congratulations you know
why most people don't win they don't
bother you have to bother it to be
intentional never again as American
Express going to call my house and ask
my wife why she would stay with a man
that won't pay his bills